[Music]
but this is our thing we like oh I just
sent this to my dad it's so sad look at
his little
legs okay oh yeah that is
[__] you want to see him get like gone
you you want to see him get up and then
like run away dude but then there's that
video of the bear falling out of the
tree when he got tranquilized and that
one's really funny yeah but it's like
obviously died we were watching it with
Josh and like I was like dude what do
you think happened to him and Josh was
like you didn't hear he broke his
[__]
back like dude he's in the [__]
hospital right now you know what pull
that up bear falls out of tree I've
realized like that kind of [__] is not
funny cuz I was at a group like at a
table with people who I'm like kind of
close to but not that close to and I was
like oh my God have yall seen that video
and I showed to them and they were like
oh yeah and I was like oh yeah I had one
of those this week weekend uh one of my
shows I just I don't know I'll black out
and say just random [__] and I just go
what's the sound you think your dad made
when he made you and the whole room was
like oh like they all like threw up
inside I was like okay going back to the
material I don't know why I said that
sorry sorry dude my big one is like
telling people that my mom is dead that
will always kill a room that will kill a
[__] room damn I'm sorry this is
hilarious I'm sorry oh damn yeah yeah I
remember this like he's just like how
did he keep that posture going down he
did a kick flip oh now he's going to
redo it like why is he climbing up the
tree he felt so bad he's like damn Fu I
got to trank myself he's like Dart me
Dart alive no so he was alive and then
they shot him and he ran up the tree oh
oh look at that
thumbnail a so embarrassing like this is
humiliating so embarrassing like my cat
will fall off the counter and he the
animals have like embarrassment like
they get embarrassed
yeah a yeah I mean that's that bear
that's the first thing I was thinking
about when it fell I like that was
cringe yeah literally he's like dude
everybody here saw me yeah everyone here
recorded me I have to go bro wait
there's so many bears falling I know
like have y seen P [__] Panda's falling
out yeah it's really cute actually's see
one yeah they're kind of dumb like what
the [__] is this Tik Tok they're showing
us cars now like literally
like he's like and here's my favorite
Ford Focus I like silver
and here's another bear falling out of a
tree I like know the Cadence of this
person's voice is how annoying about 15
miles relocate is a difficult
proposition at the animals of the return
often return and they could use and uh
animals have some habitat with oh it's
the robot they'll stay there she said oh
cool y'all's um Wi-Fi is
bad oh top comment that's very sad a he
liked the city
so under the effects how does this
affect LeBron's poor bear why' they use
the the rainbow
emoji bear Emoji pray emoji rainbow
emoji that one just doesn't feel like it
like fits in that sentence Oh gay bear
gay
bear I'll say Ty oxymoron I'm not fair
or I'm Not
Afraid
whoa SLP bro first words said this
episode I'm not afraid I am no longer
afraid I sorry I still wanted to watch
this one the what I would wear at Pearl
Harbor wait what this is crazy
Battlefield in Pearl Harbor so since
Pearl Harbor is kind of like an ocean
Battlefield terrain I think this
gorgeous vintage blue t-shirt would look
so good this is hilarious happened in
the 60s I feel like this gives a very
like vintage Vibe but yeah this t-shirt
is kind of like a windbreaker t-shirt I
think the ocean blue color just matches
so well with the whole like Pearl Harbor
Ocean Hawaii aesthetic so you guys
already know that I have to do some sort
of because the Army like I have to have
some
camons on them because I'm the star of
this Pearl Harbor War hey oh God are
those B I'm going to go along with like
BL theme because okay your Blues aren't
matching my
love they're literally not matching your
clashing it's so weird so my combat
Jordans are on now it's time combat
Jordans that's the craziest like why is
that like of all that he said that to me
is like calling dunks combat Jordans
combat Jordans was crazy yeah and he's
about to put on a bunch of pearl
necklaces oh why cuz the
ocean I don't like him cuz we are
battling in Pearl Harbor but yeah guys
yeah I like that one um I'm weing this
sponge for a weapon because just in case
when the missiles land in the water I
can block my face so I don't have to
mess up my hair or makeup I can just
block the water like this and the sponge
will absorb all of the splash my last is
this micronized
creatine this off of Amazon cuz I know
all the gym Bros use it so I think if I
eat this and share it with my other
teammates like this is what my outfit
would
be I like him saying if I eat this eat
this if I eat this share it with my
teammates is hilarious low key like he
probably would be like on top of the
food chain if he brought that if he
snuck that in I'm obsessed would love to
see their 911
fit I'm
obsessed dude bombing but what did it
say bombing but make it fashion
literally serving our nation I hope this
reaches the wrong audience so I could
watch the chaos and F in the comments
kind of already did can kids stop
looking at themselves in the camera and
use their unlimited access to knowledge
for a basic grounding in athletics and
history
lame loser let the kids have fun oh go
play flag football D yeah
literally
literally this is very high performance
trolling Andy coffin let's let's relax
on that yeah yeah all right okay um did
you know Trisha pis had Andy Kaufman was
Andy Kaufman in her bio on YouTube for
like years and no one noticed no no yeah
she had Andy Kaufman in her like bio for
years interesting which is like super
Advanced so do you think she's uh she's
been trolling everybody I think so yeah
I think she's been pretty self Weare
from the jump like I think she knows
what she's doing I mean she did the
whole she did that Do You Remember on
YouTube way back she had that whole
video like dogs don't have brains no no
yeah it she it was something like yeah
dogs don't have brains and it was kind
of like looking back I'm like oh yeah
you knew what you were doing yeah it was
this 9 Minute rant where she goes I just
don't think dogs have brains mhm like
how do they think how do they what what
do they do and it pissed off so many
people dude her coming out is like trans
and nonbinary that's was like I was like
oh my God she's the funniest person ever
she had a joke recently where she was
talking about like like uh the trans
flag or something and she was like oh my
God it's almost like a gender reveal and
then she was like oh wait wait never
mind so I don't know and I was just like
dude like you're funny dude she's so
awesome I think she's like known from
like what she was doing but also then
sometimes when she speaks about it it
sounds really sad and I'm like oh maybe
that was real yeah I think a lot of like
her crying was like real cuz I don't
know how you can fake cry like that but
um ever seen a movie hello wait actually
what is a movie what is that so movie is
this moving
picture wait they made moving pict Drew
was like oh yeah I went to that thing
where they have like people on a screen
and they like kind of to be they look
like they're moving and stuff they're
acting just say a movie bro a film a
film